so Amazon this verdict in and just in
the last few minutes this guilty verdict
for Connor Chapman found guilty of
murdering Ellie Edwards what was the
reaction in court
well our colleague inside Court's been
telling me that the family were in tears
they were incredibly happy as well when
that verdict of murder came through and
Ellie edwards's Father Tim who I spoke
to in that report there once again
looking directly at Connor Chapman as
those verdicts were read out to him as
he stood in the dark he told me that he
looked at Connor Chapman throughout the
trial to see if there was any ounce of
remorse from him any regret for what he
had done and Tim had found none the
family now outside the courtroom hugging
each other incredibly happy and
emotional with these uh verdicts it's
important as well to note that there was
a co-defendant on trial with Connor
Chapman Thomas Waring Thomas Waring a
criminal friend of Connor Chapman a
criminal Ally someone Conor Chapman
could trust the person where Connor
Chapman had taken the murder weapon to
his home the person who had assisted
Connor Chapman in burning out that
Mercedes A-Class which was used on the
night he murdered Ellie Edwards Thomas
Waring has also been found guilty of
possessing a prohibited weapon and
assisting an offender that offender of
course being Connor Chapman now um the
family we are expecting shortly to come
out and say a few words alongside
merseyside police who said it was CCTV
that played a crucial role in this
investigation they trolled through I
think it was around 1 300 hours worth of
CCTV footage and of course it was that
essentially which was played to the jury
which was incredibly overwhelming the
footage not only of the moment Connor
Chapman fired 12 bullets into a crowd of
people but also seeing him ruffling his
hair dropping the murder weapon as he
walked towards his friends house him
driving that Mercedes A-Class a car that
had been in his possession for around
three months before the attack had taken
place using false number plates
throughout that whole time he said it
was a pool car that other criminals had
used as well and then of course there
was the evidence in terms of DNA DNA
found on a red glove that Connor Chapman
had used on the night of the shooting a
builder's glove and DNA found on bullet
casing as well that was found at the
murder scene so I think the jury over
the last three and a half weeks I've
heard a wealth of evidence which
essentially boiled down to quite
overwhelming evidence to sway in the way
that Connor Chapman has today been found
guilty of the murder of Ellie Edwards
let's just recap it was 10 minutes
before Christmas Day Connor Chapman had
arrived at the Lighthouse Inn which was
absolutely packed as it usually is
almost every year on Chris Christmas Eve
where people mainly young people the age
of Ellie Edwards 26 were in that Pub
celebrating enjoying uh what was the the
festive period and Connor Chapman had
arrived just before nine o'clock that
evening it essentially done a recce of
the area looking around the lighthouse
Inn and then he went and parked his
stolen A-Class Mercedes in the car park
of the lighthouse Inn and he watched on
he waited until he saw his targets here
in selkeld and Jake Duffy two members
from arrival Estates a rival gang to
Connor Chapman this was an ongoing feud
between these two gangs he then saw
those people he approached the building
and he fired what police say was
indiscriminately towards a crowd of
people it was just four minutes before
that firing that Ellie Edwards had gone
out with her friends into the beer
garden and had gone out for a cigarette
that she was a holy innocent bystander
in this attack and I think that's really
what has been a a common um a thread
throughout this whole case is that
people were saying this was Christmas
Eve Ellie was celebrating with friends
and family like millions of people were
doing up and down the country and she an
innocent bystander was shot in the head
with two bullets and they were
unsurvivable two other targets were
seriously injured the intended targets
and then three other men as well had
sustained injuries and just going back
to those verdicts for Connor Chapman the
23 year old who at all times had
completely denied his role in this
murder he had he had pleaded guilty for
one of the counts right at the beginning
that was possession of stolen goods that
the A-Class Mercedes however he had
pleaded not guilty to murder and
throughout the whole child denied that
it was him who pulled the trigger which
killed Ellie Edwards but today the jury
found him guilty of her murder they
found him guilty of two counts of
attempted murder they found him guilty
of two counts of wounding with intent
they found him guilty of assault
occasioning actual bodily harm they
found him guilty of possessing a firearm
with intent to endanger life and found
him guilty of possessing ammunition with
intent to endanger life it's expected
that the judge will sentence Connor
Chapman tomorrow at around two o'clock
here at Liverpool Crown Court but when
we look at the reaction from the family
the sheer relief of people who for the
last six months have just been
questioning who was the person that took
Ellie Edwards life on Christmas Eve and
Tim Edwards her father had been very
emotional in court throughout the last
three and a half weeks but today in
particular it's clearly hit a man who
has been missing his daughter for the
last six months or so he was crying in
court he was incredibly emotional there
were shouts of yes in the public Gallery
the family had gone outside the
courtroom started hugging each other as
well and we are expecting for some of
the family members to come out and give
us their reaction as to what happened
but we go back and look back at the the
details of this case it was incredibly
overwhelming evidence that was presented
to this jury and I think the police Who
merseyside police who carried out this
investigation felt it was that evidence
that really what was what it was they
could put towards the jury here is the
family Tim Edwards there
very happy Tim do you want to come say a
few words
um
a few words we know that you want to you
talk tomorrow but just your reactions
now to what's happening in court today
yeah well we got to the resort we wanted
Justice for Ellie so it's always been
about
um
those two cowards in there
decided to drag it out for four weeks
put all these people through that and
everyone else around it
involved in the case can't thank the
police enough for what they did and we
got there in the end and the right
results
and you know what I help them too never
see another Christmas again have it in
their lives
hit from you in the dock you tried
so that you couldn't see I've had my
eyes on him for four weeks three weeks
four however long it's been and he has
not looked at me once because he's a
coward and that's exactly what he is I
mean I I couldn't care less about him
not even I'll never ever mention his
name and I hope he rocks in hell
how much of a relief is
the spoken to you for the last six
months ever since this happened how much
of a relief person is this it's a big
relief because now we can start again
we've been put through hell
and will be deserve now to be
given you know given the life back that
we that we had before
which should never be the same
and freaking just it's just it's it's
now a new chapter it's a new beginning
for our family
big day indeed yeah it's it's the worst
day but the best of the worst I
that's all I'd say thank you everyone